[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي شين تارو أوكاموتو ، أنا
مؤسس ومدير إبداعي
لاستوديو كيمونو مخصص لأداء بسيط
طلب مني وفريقي التفكير في
الأشياء الفريدة المختلفة التي نقوم بها باستخدام الثلج
وأردت  للتركيز حقًا على
عملية التجميد نفسها في الوقت الحالي
، فأنا جالس في المجمد الخاص بي هنا في
الاستوديو الخاص بي في كوينز نيويورك ، وأعتقد دائمًا
أن جميع سكان ألاسكا يلعبون بالجليد ،
لكنني بدأت في نحت الجليد مع والدي على
ما أعتقد عندما  ربما كان عمري 12 و 13 عامًا
عندما دخل والدي لأول مرة في
مسابقة نحت الجليد الدولية
التي استضافتها مدينة أنكوراج وكنت
شريكًا له ، كانت
هناك تجربة مروعة حقًا
كانت وظيفتي تجريف الثلج وكسر الجليد طوال
الليل ولكن في النهاية كان التمثال
جميلًا  كانت الاستجابة مذهلة ، لقد
كان شيئًا جميلًا
حقًا أنني وقعت في حب الصرخة
الصرخة
[موسيقى]
تغيير الخطة ، خطة عمل جديدة ،
خطة عمل الديكور ، أعتقد أنها رائعة
إذا نجحت ، لا تلمسها  لا أريد
أن
أفعلها وأعدها ، لقد رأيت دائمًا الجليد على
أنه مادة قائمة على الوقت
تتغير باستمرار وتتطور ، إنه هذا النوع من
التجسيد للوقت الذي يمر فيه
عنصر التجميد داخل الجليد هذا
عكس ذلك تمامًا حيث يتوقف عن الوقت
[موسيقى  ]
حسنًا ، لذا تجمد عربة الجليد منذ
الأمس ، لذا كانت هناك مجموعة ولكن كثيرًا
الليلة الماضية كانت لطيفة ورائعة أعتقد أنها رائعة
[موسيقى]
هناك تقسيم جميل حقًا
للبرد يحبس أفضل ما في الصيف
مع شيء لطيف أعتقد أن والدي هو
يضحك حقًا كل يوم بأنواع مختلفة
من الأشياء التي نقوم بها والتحديات التي
نواجهها ،
إنه هو الذي دفعني حقًا إلى الجليد
وهو في كثير من الأحيان برد محبط ليس
أكثر الأشياء المريحة للعمل بها ولكن
النتيجة النهائية دائمًا ما تكون ساحرة
وأنا دائمًا  أبحث عن شيء ممتع
للقيام به كل يوم
[موسيقى]